[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a beaucoup beaucoup de chance de
pouvoir continuer à faire du sport avec
des bénévoles et le département
continuera à aider évidemment le sport
puisque ça fait partie de notre de notre
ADN c'est essentiel et puis la Vienne
terre de sport terre de jeux 2024 mais
avec vous tous on n'est pas on n'est pas
seul on a besoin de vous tous pour ça
c'est quelque chose d'exceptionnel et
vous pouvez compter sur nous pour
pouvoir continuer de vous aider malgré
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer quelques
tensions budgétaires parfois une grande
chance de vous avoir un grand merci à
tous vive l'Open de Tennis de Poitiers
vive le sport et vive la Vienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]